erst einmal jemand aus katar in die
große stadt gezogen und nicht über so
was nach jona werden
der amerikanische sport journalist im
kreis hat die geschichte von fiona mutti
sie aufgeschrieben und er hat ihr den
titel gegeben die nun auch die
verfilmungen durch miranda erträgt
between auftakt der name des landes in
uganda in dem fiona aufwächst zu einer
königin wird sie weil wir es mit gegnern
aufnimmt die unter deutlich besseren
voraussetzungen leben
der ugandische schach welt hat einen
neuen staat und bald reicht der ruf
dieses talents über die grenzen des
landes hinaus
es handelt sich hier um eine eher
klassische erbauliche geschichte in der
die vielen widerstände die zu überwinden
sind eigentlich nur pittoreske rannte
erscheinungen sind zwei stars des neuen
afro amerikanischen kinos veredeln den
film david filo wo der in vellmar den
martin luther king spiels und luki
tanjong go bekannt aus zwölf iss längste
green auf köpfe ist dennoch als buch
eher zu empfehlen als in der filmischen
form regisseur in ihrer nähe zeigt eine
selbst noch im detail zu vorhersehbare
dramaturgie dies mit ihrem
kindchenschema auch ein bisschen zu bunt
treibt am ende sucht die regisseurin den
schulterschluss mit den figuren aus dem
richtigen leben und sofort erwacht das
interesse auf eine ganz andere weise
aber das wäre dann eben auch in sachen
kino ein ganz anderes spiel
ein dokumentarisches lebens meeres
erzählen
denkst du kannst
[Musik]
manchmal gehört man nicht an den ort an
dem man aufgewachsen
sein wohin das herz entführt wurde
[Applaus]
[Musik]